you think there's not a Joe Rogan
podcast coming out in the next 12 months
where he's not like yeah Mammoth he's
like yeah man this is good it's like
people [__] this man it's good
[Music]
so how would you guys like to try some
lab grown Mammoth meat oh meatball okay
I'm intrigued
how do they lab grow it I think that's
my question meatballs whack I want the
steak and a little bit of Tusk so we all
know about the The Woolly Mammoth yeah
which is extinct yeah for tens of
thousands of years prehistoric elephant
yes
um some holes in the genetic sequence
that they have recovered from live
tissue that was preserved over time were
was filled in using data from the
mammoth closing uh closest living
relative the African element or elephant
so they took African element jeans and
just spliced them in with the woolly
mammoth now we're just playing God you
know they used to exist all over
Northern California really that's why
that area is called Mammoth because they
found a lot of Mammoth bones oh is that
one yeah Mammoth California
what else Big Bear had big bears really
oh holy [__] at the zoo they have them
there and Tahoe has Chevy Tahoes yep a
lot of people drive Chevy tires wait
what does Downey have
Downy well
Mexicans love could say fabric softeners
very good save what else you got what
other questions you got Paramount the
movie studio Paramount Pictures nice no
what no what does Paramount mean like
big right I guess
I like mammoths though because they're
like furry elephants if you see all the
cartoon drawings of them they look like
a golden retriever [__] an elephant
and they got the long first so cute like
a golden dude golden retriever so the
product yeah the mammoths have golden
retriever first to further answer Bart's
question the process starts with cells
taken from a living animal those cells
are immersed in nutrients and grown into
meat inside of a Lab in this case the
mammoth genes were inserted into a sheep
cell whoa yeah and then the mammoth Gene
is then over expressed so it'd be more
prevalent in the final product than the
sheet so it's still part sheet that's
[__] that's a hybrid animal that's
not real Mammoth hybrid but it's
predominantly Mammoth predominant yeah
that's a liger
let me show you the picture we've never
seen a liger before look I don't want to
be honest I've probably eaten a [__] ton
of things that will be found by science
in the future to have endorsed cancer or
what they're all probably natural [__]
nah I'm good dude who eats a [__]
meatball you're talking about balloon
earlier and [__] this doesn't have a
face on it it's so big I don't want nuts
no sheep [__] prehistoric elephant if
the FDA approves it because I trust our
government thank you I'll take a bite
thank you I don't even think about them
I don't even want to eat any cow lab
grow meat yeah you wouldn't woolly
mammoth just to say you ate woolly man
no like your ancestors and [__] oh no no
I would too I'll eat a booger before I
eat that you probably already ate a
Burger Joe probably
nah I don't want to eat that that's
weird
that looks crazy thus far they claim no
one has tasted it yet but I don't
[__] why do they want to make a
meatball for why do they have all Cuts
right yeah why do they cook it like that
this is like spam you know what I mean
like you just mix it and you turn it
into a goop and you put into a shape
that's easy you can't [__] turn that
into actual meat from like the leg of
The Woolly mammo it's not gonna make it
like a chicken bone I don't want no
Mammon spam dude yeah
[Laughter]
and that's what the m and spam stands
for I'm down then yeah natural you all
know Spanish has some natural a lot of
natural [__] in it yeah I don't give a
[__] what anybody says spam is Bomb I
agree it's a bomb but it doesn't mean
it's not squirrels and [__]
nuts Muslims and Mammoth still eat it
mix of chicken pork and chicken take me
to a Zippy's that doesn't have spam did
you say chicken pork and chicken chicken
finished yeah show me a hot dog that's
just dog
there's not one and it's all kinds of
[__] yeah it's sludge have you seen
how they make it yeah it's the same it's
a leftover sludge
I'll eat it and salt if it's from Costco
I'll eat it it's like how our poop is
frankly you eat a bunch of different
stuff and it comes as one thing that's a
hard to use there thank you yeah I did
but I still love a hot dog
to me it's like baloney it's the same
thing but a different shape to me it's
like anything come out of a can I enjoy
it and I'm guilty as [__] about it I
don't want anyone to catch me eating it
yeah it's shameful yeah it's a little
shameful look I'm just optimistic and I
hope that they perfect and healthy you
know do in the healthy way lab grown
[__] because I do think that there's the
possibility if they do it right that
there's a sustainability and a you know
what I mean longevity to it you think
there's not a Joe Rogan podcast coming
out in the next 12 months where he's not
like yeah Mammoth he's like yeah yeah
man this is good it's like people [__]
on man it's good you know what I'm
saying I can already hear him saying it
you don't see it you don't see a future
where we're lab growing me and it's
actually waterproof or it's genuinely
and it's better than those [__]
Boutique ranches that got [__] cows
that are just roaming around no no no no
that's good that's gonna be like first
world first class Prestige [__] like if
you can still access real meat but there
might be a point where it's no longer
yeah it's no longer [__] viable for
us to constantly create [__] and
breathe like [__] tons of cows that are
destroying the ozone layer that are
feeding the 18 billion people that are
on planet Earth you know what I'm saying
they might sell that [__] Beyond me
[__] now [__] you know what I think's
gonna happen dump your share I think
what we're gonna find out is that the
cruelty is what made it taste so good
yeah oh my God we already know that
that's what go to the [__] dog
[__] know in China because apparently
according to these cats about cows the
reason why they're so good is because
they're taken care of and [__] drinking
beer and [__] yeah get massage I want to
go more natural I want keep giving me
them jadori chickens and the curl butter
whatever Pork yeah I want to get those
what if that's what makes it good is
that it's it's the grand duping it's
like you you let them spend a whole life
singing their baby and that Split Second
of betrayal that's what the police so it
hurts him more yeah versus if they grew
up in pain always yes and they only knew
pain right I mean it's like a turtle in
one of my Lakes
every time I eat it's
was it difficult getting the hooks out
of the turtles yeah they died every time
that's pretty rough you can't you can't
save them at that point or like you try
to pull it up but the eye comes with it
oh
we use big hooks why don't we use the
big hooks
damn dude dude if they could make the
lab meat taste like the burger patties
from McDonald's I'm upset with your
privilege bar like the fact that you're
you're just I just walked a poor yeah
they all already they have already shown
there are people out there that will
[__] take anything off the street
yeah that what I'm talking about and
we're offering them a lab girl don't eat
me what I'm talking about is that
they've already shown the health
benefits of eating a full Orange versus
drinking orange juice the more processed
[__] is the worse it is for you so I'm
like if you can't afford me don't eat me
I'm going on the stipulation that when
they perform what's the national part of
stinky tofu [__] the sticky part is
fermented so let's be good for your
digestion sounds processing sounds first
world over here I'm trying to go
backwards dude me too yeah I want
Natural Animal I want an apple off a
tree I want to grab a chicken [__] go
like this
and [__] drink the blood of the
chicken
feathers and eat that you know the old
world had apples on trees with worms in
them dude [__] that [__] how about would
you trust eating a cloned cow no not
even that too much science dad then we
got too much science in our [__]
blood man how could you say this [__]
your wife has fake boobs she's gonna get
them out shame on you oh she is what
I got nothing damn this guy's good this
guy's good this guy is a lawyer holy
[__]
impenetrable he's a natural boy this guy
this is what I call good content I'm
trying to go more natural I'm trying to
stare at the sky instead of my phone
these days too
man you gotta get a horse because you're
riding a truck that's not natural I know
if you don't play with a horse to get a
Yama you're a [__] Baker yeah yeah
you're full of [__] dude you gotta
[__] go drive a yak yeah
it could be a Chevy Yak I know dude try
as much as I can dude what else what
other natural things you want to try to
do I've been walking a lot of [__] why
don't get mad at me just walking he's
walking and walking eating whole fruits
whole fruits staring out the [__] sky
with the sun you just turn up the sun
stared at not the trees what about what
about all your barbell protein stuff
that's not I'm trying to move towards
more Whole Foods natural gummy bears
selling supplements
I mean it's hard don't sell the
supplement sell the cow
maybe we've got some bar block cows
maybe yo you guys want to buy a cow I've
been watching videos on YouTube oh
nobody said that it's a classic Barton
show video dude this out dude you get a
half a cow for like a [__] I have a
cow well because a whole cow's a lot
true I mean how do you buy a half a cow
no we'll get a cow
back out front we'll get a whole cow
right and then they'll hook it up for us
they'll dress it they'll cut it up put
it into little different packages and
[__] and then if we pitch in dude that's
a whole Year's worth of food just half a
cows a whole year yeah for all of us
yeah it's a [__] I'm down it's like 400
pounds dude dude let's get half a cow if
you eat one pound a day that's 400 days
but there's like a bunch of us and
number one like who the [__] is going to
freeze pack up hey dude [__] these guys
dibs on carne asada yeah oh no no I want
flap they do it for you yeah they do it
for you and then for you and then who's
taking the udder uh
no I want to go lay dude I wanna I would
love a filet filet mignon
let's let's seriously buy one though I
mean my friend's dad they went hunting
and they got a elk a big ass [__] elk
they took it to the butcher down and the
mountain
butcher the whole thing uh vacuum sealed
all of them labeled all the parts so you
know if you're eating the filet or the
backstrap or whatever the rib eye of the
elk and it was delicious wow see I want
to live like that see but so why don't
you the time yeah I'm busy working and I
need to know how to shoot a bow down
first yeah
you can't use your Glock 19. I would
love to but
you're [__] John Wicked I think
I'm trying to be natural [__]
as a man don't you feel weak because you
can't hunt and bring food home no you're
right the idea of bringing food home is
going to a grocery store buying five
apples
five apples yeah that feels kind of beta
during covet though right during covet I
did feel like the ultimate alpha male
going you went to go Taco Bell I'm like
I'm [__] providing dude oh you're
really stay at home I'm gonna go out
there I'm gonna risk it all I gotta go
do what I gotta do where's the man yeah
I felt that way and I'm like I had to
wait in lines there's I don't wear my
mask the whole time yep six feet I had
to be respectful because real men gotta
do the dangerous stuff that's right you
know like grocery shopping grocery
shopping is dangerous oh it's pretty
dangerous we gotta go get our meat man I
gotta get my frozen corn
you don't know if you're gonna have to
fight a Karen that day for the last
carne asada you're asking over your nose
yeah it's not over your [__] nose oh
[__] you got Karen attack you know
exactly you're gonna deal with that
trying to call the cops because your
mask's so bad you know you don't know if
an old Asian lady's gonna back into you
in the parking lot of the market every
day you risk your life that's legit now
you're gonna call the cops and guess
what are the cops gonna give you covered
you don't know you don't know
an uncertain time
there's the cops gonna give the
girlfriend
[Music]